-She was the EPA...
-MONA: Something cheerful.
(LAUGHS) ...administrator
under President Obama
who is now the director
of Harvard Center for Health
and the Global Environment,
my old job, Gina McCarthy!
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
-BILL: Hey.
-Gina, how are you?
-GINA: Good to see you.
BILL: I...
-always love having you on.
-Thank you.
Because you're
a straight-shooter,
and you are so missed
in your old job.
-I know. Don't I look good, now?
-And I... You look good now.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
And I love the way you stick up
for the agency,
and I love the way
you always put it in context.
You know, I read something
recently where you said,
"You know, the EPA,
it's not about polar bears."
-No.
-And I'm in love
with polar bears.
I think we should
save every one.
But people just don't,
I think, understand.
They've somehow got this idea
that the EPA is not for them,
that it's working against them.
-How did that--
-Just because it has the word
"environment" in it,
it doesn't mean we do
birds and bunnies
and polar bears.
-(LAUGHS) Right.
-You know?
Although, I love them,
-so don't send me
bad emails about it.
-Right.
It's really about kids.
It's about public health.
-It's about safe drinking water,
clean land. It's clean air.
-Right. It's-- Yeah.
-What is that?
-Yeah.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
-And the man who took over,
Scot Pruitt...
-Yes.
-That's not what he's about.
-That's not what he is about.
How bad is it
under Scott Pruitt?
It couldn't be worse,
right? He...
It's true. The only thing
that could be worse
is if he actually knew
what he was doing.
(LAUGHTER)
-But I think he--
-It's true.
I think he does know
what he's doing.
He knows how
to dismantle something.
Yeah, well, he's got an all-out
attack on science, for sure.
He's got an all-out attack
on the agency.
You know, he's making some
policy decisions,
but in the end, he's trying
to get rid of a lot of rules
that were put in place
that were done well,
and every time there have been
challenges in court,
he's going down.
BILL: And you know, I hate to--
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
I hate to drag religion
into things...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...but it is a lot--
I'm sorry, but a lot of these
anti-environmental people
are that way because they are
religious, excuse me, nuts...
who believe Jesus is going
to take the wheel, and-- and...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Right?
-Great song.
Great song,
but terrible policy...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
-Uh...
and that we don't have to do
anything, because,
as this fellow guy from
Oklahoma says, Inhofe,
"God's still up there."
-I know.
-You know?
"What do we need you for, Gina,
God's still up there.
Case closed."
Well, that is one way
to look at it.
EPA tends to look at science,
because science isn't
a religion, it's facts.
There ya go. Okay, so...
And we really like to make
decisions like that, so...
-So here's...
-(APPLAUSE)
Here's my problem
with regulation,
and I know we need a lot
of regulation
and I think we probably need
almost all the EPA regulation,
but we have a lot of regulation
that is really onerous.
-Even Obama used to say that.
-Hmm.
And it gives the whole thing
a bad name,
which brings me to my
garage door.
(GINA LAUGHS)
-I knew something was coming.
-I just-- Yeah.
I just wanted to get a new
garage door.
You know what you have to do
in California
to get a new garage--
And it's my garage door,
by the way.
If I want it to fall on my face,
I should be allowed.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Maybe I want to commit suicide
by garage door.
(GINA LAUGHS)
I mean, you need-- Like, I had
three or four inspections.
It took months and months
to put in a goddamn garage door.
I'm not askin' for a helipad
over my house.
And things like that give
regulation a bad name,
and thats-- and it hurts
the EPA.
I just wanted to share that
about my garage door.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
(APPLAUSE)
You don't have to answer that!
-I'm glad we settled that!
-Yes, okay...
So, here's something else, I,
you know, I...
we're probably around
the same generation.
-Yes. Generally, yes.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Okay. So, I read the obituaries.
I always have, by the way.
I always thought
they were very amusing.
Now, they're not so amusing.
-They're more relevant than
they used to be, aren't they?
-Oh, my God.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
"Ninety-three... young man"
-(GINA LAUGHS)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
What, was he hit by a bus?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
But... But, you know...
I just see the word "cancer."
Yeah.
I mean, every day. All the time.
And I remember in the '80s,
when people were dying
from AIDS,
they didn't know how
to deal with it,
and people were like,
"I see the name of this disease
every week in the paper,
we've got to do something."
But I see this word "cancer"
all the time.
I know we've always had it,
although, it was rare
in the ancient world.
We've had it more
as we go along.
Now it seems that we have--
It's just in every obituary,
and... it's because of
the environment.
It's the lead, it's the mercury,
it's the water, it's the food,
it's the oceans.
Yeah.
What don't people get?
I guess they just think
it's gonna be the next guy.
Well, I think what happened is,
because we are from
the same generation,
we remember when rivers
were burning and smoke stacks
were spewing out smoke.
Right.
It's just it's not
as visible anymore,
but it doesn't mean
it has gone away,
it means it is way more
insidious than it used to be.
I don't think I need to say
more than "Flint, Michigan,"
to remind people--
-BILL: Right.
-(APPLAUSE)
...that kids
are getting contaminated.
You know, and I...
We just have to--
Scientists have to speak
very clearly, and we have to
let scientists tell the truth.
-And we have to listen to it
and base decisions on it.
-(APPLAUSE)
You know, I...
One of my favorite things
to say when I go out is,
"Listen, this is all you
really need to know
about climate change:
Number one, it's real.
Number two, man-made emissions
caused it.
And number three,
that's why women
need to rule the world."
-(CHEERING)
-It's as simple as that.
-(LAUGHS)
-(INDISTINCT CHATTER)
(CHEERING CONTINUES)
-BILL: Okay.
-I'm sick of cleaning up
after you guys.
-BILL: No, I...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)